4 pasa Jeff Jenny frigoshin de ser
prácticamente un símbolo de la guerra a
enemigo del presidente ruso qué tan
estrecha era la relación entre ambos y
qué tan relevante era la figura de
una figura muy importante que ha sido
utilizada por Putin en distintos
escenarios y uno de ellos fue Siria tal
vez lo hemos olvidado pero las tropas
Warner que siempre han tenido una
presencia en la última década en África
libraron unas batallas muy importantes
en Siria y también en Libia por lo tanto
él no es una figura política dentro del
círculo político de Putin es más bien un
amigo de amigos no no está estrechamente
relacionado al poder de Moscú Pero ha
sido utilizado muy bien para distintos
conflictos y obviamente en la guerra
Ucrania ha sido decisivo aquí también
hay una guerra civil entre militares y
ya desde el principio de la ofensiva y
de la invasión de Ucrania hemos visto
muchos desacuerdos entre figuras en el
poder militar como y otras figuras con
el líder de Wagner free goji y a mí me
parece que hay que ver este digamos este
enfrentamiento entre militares con mucho
cuidado me ha sorprendido el anuncio que
hizo Vladimir Putin esta mañana en
televisión nacional Porque da a entender
que esto es una situación muy crítica
que lo está afectando a él directamente
en el pasado las críticas de habían sido
más bien dirigidas a los militares Y
todavía él ha sido muy cauteloso en
acusar directamente a Putin del debacle
que hay en Ucrania pero una vez más es
una figura militar en los círculos entre
entre los militares es ha sido utilizado
en la guerra pero no tiene un poder
político y es importante tomar esto en
cuenta en caso de que él quiera hacer un
golpe de estado y asumir la posición de
Vladimir Putin que me parece que sería
muy arriesgado y tal vez no creo que sea
su objetivo final ahora desde Ucrania ha
habido optimismo incluso los servicios
de inteligencia no solo pronostican el
inicio de una guerra civil sino que
también se ve esto como un colapso de
Putin es acertado llegar a estas
conclusiones teniendo en cuenta que el
grupo Wagner en este momento se
encuentra avanzando con destino hacia
Moscú casi prácticamente sin ninguna
oposición y de hecho ya la capital rusa
se encuentra
blindandose ante posible ante la posible
incursión de este grupo de Mercenarios
bueno todas estas discusiones que han
habido en el último año entre las
esferas militares de Rusia ha
beneficiado grandemente Ucrania se ve
que no hay una buena logística hay
distintos grupos estamos también
hablando la guardia nacional que
pertenece a chechenia dirigida por el
líder tan carismático y Popular en
Telegram kadir off que también ha
asumido un rol primordial en la Guerra
de Ucrania Así que hemos visto como
mucha
desintegración de la capacidad militar
de Rusia no obstante es un país inmenso
con un gran Arsenal militar y muchos
soldados
muchos soldados a su disposición por lo
que ha podido mantenerse pero
ciertamente lo que está sucediendo hoy
es claramente algo que desmoraliza toda
la a todo el ejército Ruso y Esto va a
beneficiar momentáneamente a Ucrania
porque me parece que el enfoque va a
haber va a ser más en las divisiones que
existen entre el ejército no obstante
Ucrania todavía también tiene sus
limitaciones en términos de de su
infraestructura militar a pesar de la
ayuda que ha recibido de la Unión
Europea y los Estados Unidos pero sí
creo que Esto va a ser En beneficio para
la ofensiva que han comenzado este
último mes pero no obstante no olvidemos
que este es un país con un gran
armamento nuclear y y muchísimos
soldados que desgraciadamente a muchos
han muerto en los últimos meses claro
señora Badillo usted lo mencionaba hace
un momento no solo opera en Ucrania sino
también en varios países de África Qué
implicaciones tendrá por ejemplo para el
gobierno ruso esta enemistad con el
Grupo Mercenario
el Grupo Mercenario opera a veces como
una multinacional no tiene apoyo del
gobierno ruso para establecerse en
África pero es una entidad semi
independiente no mayormente los que son
parte de Wagner son retirados de las
fuerzas militares y el servicio de
inteligencia de Rusia pero no son
directamente no trabajan para Putin como
tal hay que entender que muchas de estas
repúblicas en África utilizan el
servicio de Wagner para proteger a la
población y proteger por ejemplo ciertos
lugares de Gran valor no como Minas no
de extracción de oro y otros minerales
sumamente costosos y que tienen gran
demanda mundial por lo que Wagner se
beneficia directamente no porque esto no
se hace por obra y gracia no esto se
cobra y hemos visto que en los últimos
dos años especialmente la República
centrada africana que tienen grandes
recursos ha recurrido más en bagne para
proteger a su población que en
organismos internacionales y ellos se
benefician económicamente de esto es